foreign
this is what a Palestinian refugee camp
in mourning looks like
from chanting against Israel's
occupation
to resistance poetry recited by a
Palestinian born before Israel was
created in 1948.
and
the grief of a mother
sun is about to be buried
hours earlier Israeli forces killed 22
year olds Hamza hariosh and Samuel
shafari they recuse of an attack on an
illegal Jewish settlement the young men
were in samra's home when the raid
happened
damage that was caused by the Israeli
forced perfumes as keyboard a computer
mobile phones and ccdv footage were
taken away by the forces you've got kids
here that said that they'd heard a lot
of them turn up they heard the gunshots
and then you'll have a look here there's
blood stains one of the three men were
injured they tried to escape through
this kitchen window you can see the
watermelon all the remnants left of an
everyday functioning home and it's here
where two of them tried to escape and
when they got to the other side they
were shot by snipers
says he thought he too was going to die
this is the spot where Hamza and Sama
were killed I thought I imagine
explains he was lying down when he heard
gunshots he went to his window where the
duo refused to give themselves up he was
lucky though one of those bullets was a
stray bullet that hit his wall right
there
Witnesses say Hamza was still alive
lying on the ground but a soldier then
shot him at close range
at the funeral support for Palestinian
armed groups was visible several formed
in 2021 and are affiliated with Hamas
and Islamic Jihad Israel blames them for
the daily raids it conducts across
occupied territories the many
Palestinians say they're left with no
choice but to take up arms
Palestinians are under Israeli
occupation every day that's not new but
what's happening now under netanyahu's
leadership is clear they have an agenda
to weaken the Palestinians political
options have failed the response to
Israel's violence against us is that
Palestinians will defend their land and
people until they get their rights
these have become regular scenes across
the occupied West Bank of a community
coming together
to say their last goodbyes
Al Jazeera tulkaram refugee camp in
occupied West Bank